[Música]
el fútbol femenino estadounidense
celebra la decisión de la Us Soccer que
acordó con la jugadoras para agarres 24
millones de dólares como indemnización
por salarios atrasados y también bonos
además la federación se comprometió a
que tendrán el mismo sueldo que el
combinado masculino el reclamo que
comenzó en 2016 3 años más tarde en 2019
se formalizó cuando 28 jugadores
denunciaron a la federación ante una
corte federal de California solicitando
66 millones de dólares por daños y
perjuicios amparados en la ley de
igualdad salarial sin embargo un año
después en 2020 un juez desestimó los
pedidos de la jugadora pero permitió que
siguieran adelante sus reclamos sobre
las condiciones
se encuentran las estrellas
de 2015 y 2019 dejando atrás a sus
compañeros que ni siquiera se
clasificaron para el último mundial
disputado hasta la fecha hablamos de
Rusia 2018 y ahora para profundizar en
este tema nos acompañado en esa Córdoba
futbolista colombiana que militan el
Querétaro de la Liga Mexicana Vanessa
muy buen día gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 un gusto tenerla con nosotros nada
más ustedes se formó en el fútbol
universitario de Estados Unidos y por
eso le preguntó Qué impacto cree que
tiene esta medida en el fútbol
profesional femenino
Raúl salió muy especial para ti y para
quienes nos ven Yo creo que es un gran
momento para el fútbol femenino
Más allá de de poder lograr finalmente
el famoso y cupéque Incluso se canto
durante el Mundial cuando salía Estados
Unidos a jugar creo que el tema de la
indemnización es súper importante si
bien no fue el monto que ellos estaban
solicitando si es una forma de reconocer
que sí había cierto eh
sismo Por decirlo así Dentro de las
condiciones laborales de ellas esto si
bien empezó hace 3 años creo que siempre
hay un trasfondo mucho más largo dice
que la lucha
con un buen argumento el cambio Si
perdían Entonces se iban a meter por el
lado de que es que ellos no gana aunque
ya tengan tres mundiales encima pues
ganados Entonces digamos que también hay
que valorar mucho Esa presión con la que
jugaron me dan rápido desde su activismo
también hacia Donald Trump Así que no yo
creo que es una victoria no solamente
para las americanas sino para el resto Y
por ahí me quería meter entonces Vanessa
esto marca un presidente Para que más
Federación es el fútbol del mundo que
eran equiparar los salarios países como
Australia por ejemplo ya lo hicieron
total Normalmente se habla cuando
hablamos de equidad dentro del fútbol es
Es que las mujeres no generan lo mismo
que los hombres creo que Estados Unidos
es el único país donde sí se puede
argumentar lo contrario las mujeres si
lo han logrado y ese fue un argumento
por el cual hace un año un juez dijo que
pues realmente este argumento de ellas
no era válido pero es que hay que
entender que en Estados Unidos las cosas
funcionan un poquito distinto allá Miren
lo que generan los dos géneros no
solamente por su selección sino también
por su liga Entonces cuando miras que el
apoyo que ha tenido la mls y la
nacionalismo entre el fútbol
y lo que generan están distintos porque
obviamente la inversión de la federación
ha sido muy distinta hacia la liga
femenina y la liga masculina también
Vanessa ha jugado en España y Colombia
le preguntó Entonces qué tan desiguales
son estos salarios entre hombres y
mujeres en el fútbol profesional digamos
Cuáles son las razones Si es que las hay
para que los hombres ganan más que las
mujeres incluso cuando pues lo estábamos
hablando también con el ejemplo de
Estados Unidos las elecciones femeninas
tengan más triunfo que las elecciones
masculinas es que también es absurdo
Pues digamos que si desempeñan la misma
labor desempeñan el mismo deporte pues
deberían ganar igual y no debería haber
Esa diferencia que pues Lamentablemente
Todavía existe
las diferencias son enormes Incluso se
habla de 70 años para poder lograr a
igualdad dentro del fútbol a nivel
mundial No ya tenemos los pequeños pasos
bueno pequeños no pero casos comen
Estados Unidos que se están acercando a
eso creo que en Latinoamérica nos falta
un montón pero todo tiene que ver con la
inversión No puedes pretender que algo
te disfruto sino inviertes en él muchas
veces se critica que el femenino
tiene que ser muy subsidiado y perdón
pero si vamos a hablar de fútbol podemos
hablar del masculino sobre todo cuando
tienes toda una historia detrás
ilegales entonces Creo que todavía
estamos lejos después
del año no solamente unos meses que
tengan procesos para poder desarrollarse
plenamente los hombres desde que son
niños tienen un balón a los pies las
mujeres no Y además tenemos un proceso
Vanessa también por último Le quiero
preguntar en estos últimos años Cuánto
ha crecido el fútbol femenino hablo de
espectadores patrocinantes el dinero que
se le inyecta a las ligas femeninas de
fútbol Cómo ha crecido
que no hay que ir muy lejos para verlos
femenino
por lo menos ya sabemos que hay un
Estados Unidos que son muy buenas no O
sea creo que desde ahí tenemos que
comenzar a medir al final lo que
realmente
impactamente este proceso no tiene O sea
no hay forma
femenina
[Música]
probablemente va a ser a lo mejor pues
igual en todos los sentidos a la
femenina en su opinión diga en un futuro
no tan lejano cuánto tiempo le ve
primero depende de qué país
los países están en situaciones muy muy
distintas y hablo por Colombia creo que
yo le pongo unos 10 15 años más
realmente para poder llegar a este a ese
punto de equilibrio
gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en ese espacio y directo
América vas a decirle que las apoyamos
en esta lucha Y cuando quiera pues aquí
tiene una ventana para hablar de deporte
para hablar de fútbol femenino Gracias
Vanessa
No gracias Y ustedes y también para
Resaltar estas noticias positivas que
han sucedido en este por un abrazo muy
grande un abrazo Vanessa desde nuestro
estudio en Bogotá